[Music]
you earn about today with the illegal
alien coming in very sadly from Mexico
and you saw what happened to that
incredible beautiful young woman should
have never happened
illegally in our country we've had a
huge impact but the laws are so bad the
immigration laws are such a disgrace
we're getting them changed but we have
to get more Republicans that was the
president earlier tonight is West
Virginia rally lamenting what was the
ultimate the untimely death of of Molly
Tibbets we feel so sorry for her family
that I don't thought some presence we
said earlier go out to them this is a
tragedy that can be prevented more on
reaction to this horrific story author
of the book why we fight Fox News
national security strategist dr.
Sebastian Gore co-author of the Geraldo
show Fox News correspondent at large
where Aldo Rivera where although this to
me I see Kate Steinle
a beautiful young girl her entire life
stalked by this guy apparently according
to Fox News reports earlier tonight and
brutally murdered again an illegal
immigrant in this country we have to fix
this problem this should be the end of
it for everybody
build the wall keep a door we'll call it
the Geraldo door seriously because you
and I have disagreed on some aspects of
immigration stop drugs stop human
trafficking control who comes into this
country we love you come from anywhere
we just need to vet you so you're a part
of our family we don't care where you
come from just we need to know that
you're safe and secure for the people
that are here you know show and I
totally understand the anger that so
many people are expressing and feeling
over this horrible case and my heart
breaks for the Tibbets family it really
does this is absolutely horrific I feel
so sorry for them as the father of five
it is so so saddening to me it's
saddening for what this family has
suffered and it is sad because it will
fuel the malignant false notion that
this
terrible savage crime is characteristic
of this population the 12 million
undocumented immigrants in this country
are not all ms-13 no that's absolutely
true you're right but we've got to be
able to try and vet those that are here
because there's no argument I have no
there's no distance between us on that
point but what I fear is that this case
will now become the rallying cry to
deprive the dreamers of their of their
protected status to to harshly crack
down on the mom and pops who've been
here for years and and and care for our
babies and Motorola's and wash our
dishes everybody out let's dr. korkor
let's make sure I would love that I
would love that I would hire every board
in the country the poorest father I know
you tell people come on we'll give you a
yellow pass we'll figure out who you are
and what your status is I just I just
want everyone to know my dad I just want
to quickly say my dad Cruz Rivera and
this guy's name is Rivera please say you
wonder how I feel about this my dad when
he was alive Cruz Rivera we moved from
Brooklyn to Long Island from the
Democratic part of Brooklyn
to Republican Long Island all we wanted
to do is fit in every time there was a
violent crime my dad would pray that it
wasn't a Latino because the the
community was already beleaguered and
now people that are gonna serve ative
they're not then anybody but dr. Gorka
is we do have things we can do and we're
not doing them Sean Kate Steinle should
never have died now Molly's life has
been ripped away from her
by an illegal alien Americans should
never forget these women never forget
these young girls and we should never
rest until the wall is built and every
single criminal like this is removed
from this country or put in prison No
nobody has the right to come to America
and to be an American the sanctuary
cities the outrageous catch and release
policies of the Obama administration are
because of one reason and one reason
alone and it's not humanitarianism it's
because the Democrat Party that wants
legal votes that's the only for their
families and I know you mean it a rather
more